como nos auto clasificamos yo diría que
un 6 si tuvieran que compararse con los
demás en función de un rasgo específico
que dirían sobre cómo los ven y cómo se
ven reunimos a seis personas les
vendamos los ojos y les pedimos que se
clasificarán entre sí según lo atractivo
que pensaban que eran luego se quitaron
las vendas de los ojos para reacomodarse
esta es la clasificación
mido entre 175 y 178 soy rubio blanco y
tengo pk mido entre unos 65 tengo el
cabello hasta los hombros castaño oscuro
negro soy
morena tengo el pelo rizado negro corto
estilo mohicano
tengo muchos tatuajes si tengo en el
brazo un tatuaje en el cuello tengo
tatuajes en la cara en un lado de la
cabeza tengo 2 escorpiones
tengo ojos marrones unos ha sido 175
cabello castaño corto en este momento
cuando crece se pone algo rizado tengo
algo de vello facial y tengo un lindo
bigote tengo casi todo lo que tienen los
demás los orejas los ojos nariz no lo sé
que soy de piel morena cabello negro
mido
159 no no olviden
peso 52 kilos han ido 168 el cabello es
rubio pero me lo tiñó color plateado
gris mi pregunta para todos es te
sientes atractivo tienes confianza en ti
mismo la forma en que me expreso no es
la más convencional así que me costó
mucho trabajo estoy muy orgullosa de lo
que también yo pienso que soy muy linda
he vuelto muy confiado en los últimos
tres años y siento que por eso me veo
más atractivo yo me siento apuesto me
tomo tiempo llegar a este lugar pero
ahora me siento bien quisiera saber qué
les gustaría cambiar de sí mismos antes
mencioné que quería operarme la parte
superior eso sería sólo porque tengo
disforia de género y me identifico como
no binario solo me ayudaría a sentirme
más alineada conmigo misma supongo que
mi objetivo este año es tener más
músculo me operaría la nariz porque es
bastante plana y cada vez que quiero
usar anteojos siempre es una lucha
porque tengo que empujarlos hacia arriba
diría que me operaría la nariz pero mi
gemela le molestaría que lo hiciera
tienes una gemela si somos idénticas a
ella le destrozaría que lo hiciera pero
lo he pensado mucho quisiera engordar un
par de kilos el cabello cuando crece no
puedo controlarlo no puedo hacer nada he
probado todo tipo de productos y cortes
de cabello pero no lo he logrado por eso
lo uso por como nosotros clasifica la
belleza está en el ojo de quien la mira
así que no sé no podría decirlo yo digo
18 yo diré que un sólido 9 porque
todavía tengo cosas que mejorar yo diría
que un
6 está
falto eso espero
deben clasificarse en función de quién
es el más atractivo todos quieren decir
un número donde creen que les gustaría
colocarse sé que es algo muy difícil
suena es muy confiada así que te pondría
más arriba la cualidad más atractiva que
tiene una persona es la confianza si
estoy de acuerdo entonces hay quizás
quieres moverte hasta aquí
dónde estás estoy al final de la fila
estoy de acuerdo así
quienquiera que esté a mi derecha siento
que esa es una persona muy atractiva
porque siento que tiene confianza en sí
misma y es positiva y a mí me gusta ser
amiga de personas así estás aquí sí a la
derecha
por dios gracias muy bien alguien me
ayudaría a uno sola a donde les gustaría
que me mudara de segunda
estoy de acuerdo los demás también
[Música]
a alguien
piensa que no debería estar donde está
en este momento me siento muy bien donde
estoy ahora perfecto en gira te sientes
como dónde estás ahora deberías
convierte antes dijiste que no querías
asignarme un número creo que tienes
mucha confianza así que deberías moverte
un poco hacia arriba
bien
dónde me colocarían tres o cuatro creo
que esa debería ser la primera quieres
cambiar concluye de acuerdo
bien sea y es la 1 aliados y cali 3 no
en cuatro con ratzinger a seis habíamos
hablado de georgianos y donde tercera o
cuarta la tercera
está bien disculpa cómo se sienten ahora
sí ahora me siento muy bien se debe
clasificar quién es el más atractivo con
los ojos abiertos
me quite la venda y el maquillaje me
corría por la cara y eso fue terrible
porque todos podían verme
cumpló sorprendió cómo se veían todos ni
uno solo coincidía con lo que había
imaginado que lee tu zona vas mucho más
alto
y estaba más arriba pensé yo
sinceramente conrad eres como 'the
imaginé
que alguien parecía ser más alto
podríamos empezar con eso
o alguien parecía ser más bajo
creo que nadie quiere herir los
sentimientos a los demás siento que
ahora somos uno pero estoy para eso los
registramos para ello no me ofender y
bueno a mí me atraen los hombres así que
podría opinar sobre él y estaría bien
cuál es tu opinión
es un hombre activo
quieres cambiarte sí claro me acuerdo me
cambiaré me cambiaré ahora pero la la
discusión sigue en pie si no se es una
sensación muy incómoda decirte que
debería estar más alto que tú porque
creo que soy más atractivo que tú
quieres que ella sea nueva
deberías mover muy bien todo moverme
quieres moverme cambiaré
volviendo a lo de antes siento que
conrad y loren deberían cambiar
pero sé que te hemos vuelto a cambiar
así que esa fue solo como sea todos
pueden opinar y
luego se sienten bien en el puesto que
están si alguien se siente mal o no muy
bien
oigan al ser no binaria estoy más allá
de mi cuerpo por lo que ser percibida
como una mujer con unas formas
convencionales de feminidad no no es mi
caso así que evaluar quién es más
atractivo es muy incómodo porque cada
uno tiene elementos que lo hacen único
en su estilo la gente puede ser hermosa
por fuera y ser tan fea por dentro yo no
necesito la imagen completa de todo y
creo que por eso eres la número uno es
decir todos los habitantes no está bien
alguien se siente incómodo todos nos
sentimos muy incómodos no todos los días
entras a una habitación con otras
personas
en verdad estamos filmando un vídeo o se
trata de una estafa esa fue la parte
para mí siento que evocamos nuestras
propias imágenes en uno en nuestra
cabeza así que tener que repensarlo por
completo cuando nos quitamos las vendas
de los ojos fue un poco desorientador
para mí la belleza está dentro y la
confianza es el mejor accesorio que
puedes tener para cualquier atuendo que
estés usando sentirse bien con quién
eres y el atractivo viene como resultado
de eso he pasado por tantas versiones de
mí misma para llegar a este punto estoy
orgullosa y fue reafirmante que me
pusieran en ese valía te puedes poner en
la fila con los demás no lo estoy estoy
confundida
[Risas]
solo ve hacia el medio bien gracias
eso es bueno porque tengo una pregunta
que hacer ahora
como me pongo qué
[Risas]